allez regardez bien 14 mois qu'on a par
ailleurs travaillé derrière ce rideau de
fer dix mille mètres carrés dédié à la
fête
patrick est à la tête depuis 22 ans de
l'une des plus grandes discothèques de
centres villes d'europe depuis le 13
mars 2020 plus aucun fêtards à l'horizon
à la tristesse se mêle désormais chez
patrick la colère et l'incompréhension
je voudrais enfin il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont cumulés la colère elle
est effective et présentait bien
évidemment et bars ont été ouverts on
est restés fermés on nous a traités de
non essentielle c'est un additionnel de
tous tout le monde parlait de la nisa
sion et ne couvre absolument pas les
pertes colin mon cas je cumule humaines
etc où seulement 3 mois 3 mois sur
quatorze au moins c'est une route en un
an
patrick a perdu 5 à 6 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires sont comptés
quelques investissements pour réaménager
sa discothèque
car le chef d'entreprise pensait
initialement pouvoir ouvrir en juin 2020
faire regarder ce que nous avions fait
quand on devrait le 21 juin on avait
aménagé une partie donc deux
établissements avec des terrains de
boules ça faisait partie des
aménagements qui était prévu donc on a
tout arrêté tout stoppé on avait les
aliments se taira savez le concert on
avait aménagé comme nous palais qu'il
fallait des jauges des limites séparé
avait des tonneaux et s'est donc on est
en train de réaménager tranquillement je
comprends pas ils ont ouvert dès des
choses qui étaient totalement petit hit
est en effet de danu n'aurait pu ouvrir
à l'entrée c'est dommage je voulais
réaliser pas là on avait un contrat pour
compte et on avait un appareil qui sert
après la température à ces événements on
avait tout prévu avec un protocole
c'était bord terminèrent nous a laissé
aucune chance nous a même pas reçu quoi
ce que ses patrons de discothèques
dénonce aujourd'hui c'est le manque de
visibilité
à l'image de laurent propriétaire
notamment d'une boîte de nuit de 800
mètres carrés dans le centre ville de
bordeaux
impossible pour lui de donner des
indications précises à chailles cost son
dj mentale les affres un petit peu sur
la reprise
bourg aucune aucune aucune aucune au
bénin on va se préparer au cas où
mais voilà aucune visibilité pour un
saignement on ne sait rien autant on
peut comprendre qu'on est fermée au vu
de la houle de la crise' haut niveau
depuis des mines sais pas c'est une de
l'ordre mais c'est un manque de
visibilité pour un entrepreneur ccc tél
donc je dirais pas qu'ils sont très
compliquées si aujourd'hui discothèque
on n'est pas invités pour la réouverture
dont on parle aujourd'hui inquiets qui
fait l'actualité
si on n'est pas sûr n'est pas un mythe
est ouverture qu'on nous le dise le fit
comme les potées nouveau discothèque
trop dangereux vous êtes espy awards et
aux années puis rendez vous en septembre
avant un manque de visibilité qui pèsent
aussi sur les finances comme nous
l'expliquent shy cost lui est
auto-entrepreneur
malgré les aides perçues de l'état le
manque de certitudes sur l'avenir est
difficile à gérer pour cet artiste ça va
être un moment dur parce qu'au final on
a tapé sur les économies et tout ça et
c'est vrai que comme on voit pas le bout
on sait pas trop où on va donc on essaie
de faire attention mais sans trop savoir
comment pourquoi ça faire attention à
quoi donc c'est un peu dur
financièrement parce que on sépare du
touquet ce qu'il en est de demain la
levée des restrictions en france devrait
intervenir à partir du 3 mai prochain
quant aux réouverture des discothèques
il faudra sans doute encore patienter
selon le président du syndicat national
des discothèques depuis l'arrivée du coc
vie 19 environ 430 clubs ont déjà mis la
clé sous la porte soit un tiers des
boîtes de nuit française